I have three short stories for you today
to kick off this a Friday like Wednesday
show because of the Thanksgiving holiday
starting with Fox News host Tucker
Carlson who strangely said on his
program that he's rooting for Russia in
the conflict with Ukraine what exactly
that means we don't know saying both
that he was serious and later on in the
show that he was joking
I guess he's covering all bases no
matter who sees the video it was a joke
and it's serious
take a look so hunter Biden did not no
harm by not actually like hunter Biden
but that's totally corrupt and you know
it why is it worse to ask about it than
it is to do it because people are dying
on the front lines you think it's and
why should that root for Russia which I
am because those of us who are watching
myself who think democracy preserving
democracy is important when Dick Cheney
said what the Russians did was an attack
a warlike attack on the US and I think
if Donald Trump gets off the hook on
this he's gonna put the arm on the
Chinese okay so there he says he's
rooting for Russia then later in the
show clearly Tucker Carlson tipped off
that maybe it wasn't the wisest thing to
say that you're rooting for Russia
against Ukraine a historical ally of the
United States so then he did that it was
a joke thing I'm really rooting for the
United States trace Gallagher the great
Chris Gallagher thank you right time now
before we go earlier in the show I noted
that I was rooting for Russia in the
contest between Russia and Ukraine of
course I'm joking I'm only rooting for
America so is this the biggest deal in
the grand scheme of things for Tucker
Carlson not really he said immigrants
make our country dirty he said white
supremacy is a hoax he said many other
things so in the grand scheme of things
this pales in comparison it is
interesting though that he clarifies I'm
actually rooting for the United States
of course with the historical alliance
of the United States and Ukraine you
would imagine that that would not equate
to supporting Russia against Ukraine
just a very strange thing in general for
Tucker Carlson to say and very
interestingly this next story is a very
very serious of clips
Tucker Karl
was called out on Fox News by a guest
and it was extraordinarily worth
watching particularly because of how the
host interviewing the person calling out
Tucker got visibly upset let's go to
that next the David Pakman show is
possible thanks to sponsors like VIN
Charo watches giving everyone in our
audience 15% off your entire order when
you go to david pakman.com slash watch I
just got a couple of new watches from
these guys and I love them I got the
Kairos limited release gold reserve set
which is very cool I love the white face
the simple band and everything about it
it's a perfect size for my wrist really
great choice I also picked out the
Ventura bellwether in silver and white
and what I love about this one number
one the Roman numeral at the top of the
face the white face is great this is a
chronograph model and I love the blue
leather band it's just a really nice
looking watch everybody who sees me wear
this one always asks about it what I
like about Ventura as a watch brand is
you're getting quality and you're
getting a watch where it's clear as soon
as you open the box that a lot of care
and artisanship went into the design and
the way that the watch is put together
I'm not interested in paying thousands
of dollars for a watch when I can get
one that's reasonably priced and looks
just as nice and has terrific build
quality and that's exactly what venero
is in the business of doing putting a
ton of craftsmanship into their watches
making them available for a hundred and
fifty two hundred bucks you really can't
go wrong check them out at david
pakman.com slash watch support the
people who support our show and you'll
save fifteen percent when you use that
link